das Beste ist am Ende doch wieder
Radfahren und jemand der das genauso
sieht wie sie ist diese Frau die wir
Ihnen hier zeigen ihr Name ist Julia
Hamburg Julia Willi Hamburg heißt die
Frau sie ist 14 Ministerpräsidentin von
Niedersachsen zeigen wir Ihnen hier das
Bild doch aus dem Wahlkampf als sie mit
diesem Plakat Wahlkampf gemacht hat
jetzt ist diese Frau Kai Ebel sitzt bei
VW im Aufsichtsrat
ja habe ich auch nicht verstanden
natürlich ist sie geeignet so eine so
ein Posten einzunehmen weil
sie Verantwortung für ihr Bundesland
übernimmt und weil Volkswagen natürlich
ein ganz relevanter
Wirtschafts Player in Niedersachsen er
ist gar keine frei ich sage Ihnen die
Arbeitsplätze in Niedersachsen
und ich will hier gar keine Werbung für
irgendwen machen aber Volkswagen würde
ich sagen ist vielen anderen deutschen
Automobilherstellern voraus wenn es
darum geht innovative Konzepte zu
entwickeln so und ich glaube dass das
Volkswagen gar nicht weh tut und dass
Betriebsrat ist absolut aushält sich
auch kritisch steht vorzustellen
ich bin nicht befugt für VW zu sprechen
ich weiß dass die Firma ich weiß das VW
sehr sehr kämpft und ich bin entsetzt
dass man für solche wichtige Ämter 19
nimmt die wirklich nicht aber auch gar
nichts an berufliche Qualifikation
vorweisen können aber das ist ein
anderer
diskutiere das ist das was ist vorbei
aber das ist jetzt hier billige Polemik
das Land Niedersachsen ist mehr als
Aktionär von Volkswagen und zwar
Niedersachsen wird von Menschen
repräsentiert die gewählt wurden
demokratisch gewählt worden und die
sitzen jetzt im Aufsichtsrat wie das
immer Tradition eine Frau ist also das
ist doch man kann nicht also das ist
kritisieren dass wir es hinterfragen
weil es eine Frau ist das ist eine sehr
große Problem
jemand der ein autofreies Niedersachsen
möchte ist der ist die die richtige für
einen VW Autokonzern Aufsichtsrat
zumindest richtig dass darüber eine
politische Diskussion geführt wird
wer Autos
nicht mag der sollte nicht in einem
Autokonzern im aussichtsratsraum
Millionen von von Nutzern auf der einen
Seite und auf der anderen Seite und
viele Arbeitnehmer die auch um ihre
Existenz Angst haben wie geht es
eigentlich weiter mit der
Automobilindustrie und sowas
verantwortungsloses dann zu machen das
ist schon problematisch trotzdem
dieselskandal vielleicht hat es geholfen
wenn im Aufsichtsrat eine Person
gesessen hätte die kritische geguckt
hätte und da muss man sich überhaupt mal
deutsche Aufsichtsräte angucken dafür
ist der zuständig das hätte man in der
vergangen können die Frage ist ob jemand
richtig aufgehoben ist der das gar nicht
will der das Auto gar nicht mag Frau
Kappe das ist doch eine Frage mit der
sich auseinander dass die Politiker doch
genauso gewusst die sitzen ja mit dem
gleichen Wort
für Niedersachsen im Aufsichtsrat sitzen
dann waren sie offensichtlich weniger
am Aufsichtsrat von VW sitzen sondern ja
das ist doch ein weltumspannender
Konzern der unheimlich viele ja
erfolgreicher aber
kritische Distanz mit kritischer Distanz
das ist so genau das Problem man hat zu
eng zu im selben Boot gesessen deshalb
ist unser riesiges Skandal passiert uns
allen das darf nicht passieren
ist Politikerin und es geht auch nicht
um autofrei ist Niedersachsen sondern es
geht um eine neue moderne
Verkehrspolitik die mit weniger Autos
auskommen muss und wir sehen
differenziert es geht nicht um Auto frei
das will keiner sondern es geht um
weniger und was machen wir dann
Innenstadt sie haben völlig recht was
machen wir im ländlichen Verkehr wie
kriegen wir die Menschen von A nach B
aber wir können uns nicht blind an einer
alte wunderbare Technologie es sind
deutsche Autos sind die besten
Dieselmotoren haben die besten
Dieselmotoren ich habe über Diesel auch
promoviert irgendwie über bankomotoren
habe ich da auch ein bisschen aus aber
irgendwann ist Schluss mit dieser
Technologie das weiß die Welt und
deshalb müssen wir jetzt Umsteuern wir
haben die kompetent nie was sie machen
Weltmeister
aber wir müssen jetzt momentan wir
müssen jetzt sehen dass wir unsere
heimischen Märkte dazu tüchtigen genau
die Antworten von morgen jetzt zu
produzieren das haben wir mal definiert
Zeit und die Jahrhundertwende geschafft
das müssen wir wiederholen na dann
müssen wir nicht an was allem was neues
machen
Sie nehmen einfach Behauptung als Gesetz
weil sie sagen das ist eine Technologie
keine Zukunft hat und die Welt ist davon
los das ist aber nicht richtig ein paar
Zahlen ich habe China gesagt immer mal
Californien in Kalifornien über dem Jahr
20 30 z.B der Diesel nach dem jetzigen
komplett regenerativ das heißt nicht
mehr CO2 belastend sein das noch eine
tolle Entwicklung
nachlesen das macht zum Beispiel Philips
66 ein Hersteller von mineralio das sagt
die kalifornische
Gesellschaft die das eben dort auch
einführt das wird weltweit gemacht ist
der Weg wir müssen neben der
Elektromobilität es schaffen dass wir
den Kraftstoff weltweit eben nicht mehr
auf Erdölbasis anbieten sondern auf
Basis entweder von modernen
Bio-Produkten im Reststoffen von mir aus
auch Pflanzen Abfällen damit auch keine
Krankheit Diskussion auf der einen Seite
unten das wäre aber
Verkehrsminister
wir haben jetzt gerade im Haushalt dazu
ein Beitrag geleistet den man in dieser
Woche abstimmen dass wir eben
postversielle Mobilität fördern wollen
weil das ein wichtiger Schwerpunkt ist
der wir werden im Jahre 2035 immer noch
30 Millionen Dieselfahrzeuge in
Deutschland haben und die müssen wir
auch betankt werden und die da wollen
wir auch einen Beitrag zum Klimaschutz
leisten und da ist doch die Frage wie
kann man das machen und das kriegen sie
eigentlich nur hin indem sie diese an
den Markt bringen die einen höheren
Anteil von aber bringen Sie einmal auf
den Punkt das konnte er kocht das konnte
jede ganz klar sagen was ist für Sie die
Partei die den Verkehrsminister stellt
die Zukunftstechnologie ist dass die
E-Mobilität oder sind das ist
synthetische Kraftstoffe ja wir wollen
das gerade nicht festlegen wir glauben
nämlich nicht dass die Politik
entscheiden kann was die Technik von
morgen ist sondern das wollen wir den
Menschen überlassen die sich damit
auskennen ja die haben ja gigantische
Summen an fördern deshalb sagen
wir ja auf europäischer Ebene ist der
verbrenner motor nicht tot sondern er
soll weiser existieren er soll eben mit
anderen Kraftstoffen befüllt werden das
ist unsere Politik wir diskutieren doch
jetzt hier als wenn wir diejenigen
werden die die ganze Welt versauen und
wir Deutschen müssen wieder mit hoch
Kopf vorne ran marschieren und sagen wir
retten die Welt wir machen es richtig
wir kommen jetzt mit nachhaltigen Autos
und wir tragen doch wenn ich das richtig
gehört habe darf ich eben Ausreden ich
möchte noch nicht so schreien meine
Stimme
1,8% haben wir glaube ich am gesamten
CO2-Ausstoß den verursachen wir dann
würde ich sagen dann fangen wir doch mal
vielleicht mit Amerika anfangen mit
China an mit Indien also ich war in den
Ländern ja auch viel unterwegs was da
alles auf den Straßen rumfährt was da
hinten drauf kommt also da wird mir
wirklich schlecht da merkt man auch
schon die Luft also da sind wir nicht
die ersten die vorne weg marschieren
müssen ist meine Vorbild sein wir sind
doch ja weil
auch Märkte definieren können weil wir
mal die besten Techniken hatten sogar
Arbeitslosen das ist doch wir können
doch jetzt mal die Zeichen der Zeit
erkennen das heißt wir müssen natürlich
auf synthetische Kraftstoff da ist doch
keiner dagegen die muss aber auf
regenerativ geschafft
Klasse wir dieses Fenster haben jetzt
haben wir die Debatte jetzt aber wir
müssen runter mit den Emission wir haben
ein Urteil des bundesver oder ein
Beschluss des Bundesverfassungsgerichts
das ist ja gut ja wir müssen aber runter
mit den Emissionen wir müssen da runter
der Verkehr hat es bisher nicht
geschafft und ein großer Teil sind die
Verbrenner und wenn wir es schaffen bei
uns dieses zu schaffen mit modernen ne
damit weniger weil wir dann als Vorbild
von der Welt auch Anerkennung und dann
unsere merken
wollen
die Funktion gehört dann auch dass
unsere Arbeitsplätze ganz vorbildlich
gestrichen sind und mittlerweile in
China sind dass unsere Vorbilder ich war
lange ich war zehn Jahre lang in der
nationalen Plattform elektromotiv jetzt
hat die MPM gegeben es gibt ja sehr
viele mehr Experten als wir hier am
Tisch sind ungefähr 15 Jahren da drüber
nachdenken inklusive Metall der
Arbeitgeber der Politik und wir haben
einen gemeinsamen Pfad aufgemacht dass
wir wenn wir jetzt in die neuen modernen
Technologien aber autonomes fahren wir
mal ein Thema hinein investieren würden
mehr Digitalisierung machen el mask Mass
hervor Software schlägt Hardware bei uns
in der Industrie ist noch hart wäre
schlecht Software müssen also
Produktionsprozesse umstellen wir müssen
effizienter produzieren wir müssen mit
weniger Autos mehr Dienstleistungen
schaffen dann werden wir unterm Strich
mehr Arbeitsplätze erhalten und sogar
mehr schaffen als wir wenn wir
festhalten an einer Verbrenner
Technologie die deutlich zurückgehen
wird das ist nicht nur im Emission geht
sondern darauf einfach nur mal den
Individualverkehr abzusehen
[Musik]